jour mathieu desmarais merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous ce matin en direct sur
rt france à leur mobilisation de la
confédération paysanne aujourd'hui
contre la politique agricole commune
que craignez vous concrètement avec
cette réforme qui va être en vigueur à
partir de l'année prochaine donc bonjour
juste pour préciser par rapport aux
images qu'on a vus avant c'est vrai que
c'est pas trop notre style de de fin de
manifestation donc en fait là je pense
que c'était plutôt des images la
delahaye de la fnsea nous on va plutôt
dernière pièce plutôt autrement donc là
par exemple comme aujourd'hui on va
aller faire une manifestation à lyon où
on va emmener des bottes et on va
déposer sur la place bellecour des
bottes vide qui va correspondre
justement au nombre d'agriculteurs qui
auront disparu ces dernières années quoi
voilà à cause de justement cette
politique agricole commune alors qu'est
ce que vous lui reprochez à cette
politique agricole commune qui soutient
je le rappelle beaucoup d'agriculteurs
en france celle enveloppe qui va baisser
c'est les petites exploitations qui sont
menacés selon vous en fait c'est surtout
la répartition des aides
c'est à dire que la répartition des
aides elle a toujours favorisé j'irais
plutôt les très grosses exploitations et
les petites exploitations justement nous
on demande que les premières les
premiers hectares par exemple soient
soient aidés plus que les clés derniers
hectares on demande aussi que tu les
fonds aillent plutôt aux paysans c'est à
dire la halle à l'actif plutôt qu à
l'hectare parce que pour l'instant en
fait la politique qui a été menée depuis
ces dernières années n'a fait
qu'amplifier le phénomène de
regroupement des fermes et de
grossissement des fermes avec ce qu'on
voit l'arrivée c'est à dire moins
d'agriculteurs sur le site sur le
terrain quoi et avec des conditions très
très très près de précaires quoi la
politique agricole commune qui va aussi
mettre en avant des critères davantage
écologique pour pour en bénéficier ça
aussi c'est un danger pour les
agriculteurs moi je crois plutôt que
c'est une honte c'est une possibilité
justement de
de rentrer dans le dans notre vrai défi
en fait de battre de notre planète
aujourd'hui on voit avec le co vite de
ce qui se passe on voit avec le
réchauffement climatique
c'est pas demain qu'il faudra faire la
transition écologique c'est maintenant
donc il vaut mieux justement faire un
une pac qui qui encourage le fait qu'on
aille sur une agriculture plus verte
plus vertueuse ou les agriculteurs qui
économisent plus d'énergie qu'ils sont
plus autonomes au niveau de leur ferme
c'est à dire qu'ils soient pas dépendant
de deux d'autres intrants qui arrivent
de l'extérieur ou qu'il faut produire
avec une forte énergie
donc nous l'idée c'est plutôt justement
de favoriser justement le ballet les
fermes qui vont aller dans le sens de
l'environnement et dans le sens de la
delà de l'économie d'énergie quoi et ça
c'est ce que prévoit également la pac
sauf que c'est quoi c'est une échelle
différente pour les critères sont
différents pour aller vers davantage de
respect c'est à dire que oui lab la pac
va dans ce sens mais pas assez vite pas
assez fortement quoi c'est à dire que
les budgets alloués en fait ce sont
quand même ici
ils y vont c'est sûr mais à petits pas
quoi et je pense que là il faudra un
grand coup d'accélérateur faudrait qu'on
y aille à grands pas quoi faudrait qu'on
accélère en fait au niveau 2 de la la
mise en place de tous deux de ces fonds
là pour que pour qu'il me pour que
l'agriculture aille mieux demain sachant
qu'aujourd'hui c'est quand même une
volonté des consommateurs
aujourd'hui énormément de gens veulent
justement une agriculture plus vertueuse
ne veulent plus de ces fermes usines ou
de ces fermes qui produisent des grosses
quantités avec avec une qualité qui
n'est pas qu'il ait pas au rendez vous
quoi cette c'est vrai avec notre
agriculture paysanne je pense qu'on
arrivera à relever ces défis là quoi
voilà et donc il faut que quelques
l'état aille dans ce sens là ministre de
l'agriculture vous soutient et ben alors
moi je peux pas vous dire exactement
parce que c'est pas moi qui suis aux
réunions ministérielles
après je pense qu'il ya des discussions
je pense que plus il ya des agriculteurs
qui vont nous soutenir bas plus ministre
va entendre nos revendications
voilà donc c'est vrai que pour l'instant
il n'est pas à 100% derrière nous
tu démarres est on le sait vous êtes
éleveurs néanmoins il ya beaucoup de
difficultés également je parle du
contexte global avec les lots climat
très rude notamment ce matin encore ça
aussi c'est un coup dur supplémentaire
pour l'agriculture française
de toute façon tous qui tout ce qui
arrive
en plus du reste comme par exemple le
gel qu'on a vu ces dernières ces
derniers jours c'est vrai que ça ça ça
mais encore un coup sûr sur les
exploitations
surtout celles qui qui qui démarrent ou
celles qui ont des problèmes un petit
peu financiers en ce moment eh ben c'est
sûr que ça va
il va plutôt y avoir des arrêts de ferme
que d'encouragement alors c'est vrai que
le gouvernement a promis donc d'aider
ces fermes là donc j'espère qu'il ira
jusqu'au bout et que justement il faut
je pense qu'il faut pas régler les
problèmes au coup par coup avec des
enveloppes
je pense qu'il faut changer notre notre
système d'agriculture dans le fond pour
que justement on arrive à relever ces
défis là sans avoir besoin de reverser
justement des primes au cas par cas quoi
alors vous parlez des des paysans des
jeunes paysans qui s'installe les
attirer davantage sachant que beaucoup
d'éleveurs partent aussi à la retraite
est ce que le le métier attire toujours
je pense que le métier attire toujours
mais on est toujours dans le même
problème aussi de fond c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui quand vous avez des
fermes qui sont plus en plus grosse vous
avez un budget de reprise qui énorme et
qui dépasse énormément donc les les
possibilités de chacun
donc souvent c'est le voisin ce qui
calait reins solides et bien lui il peut
reprendre
voilà vous avez même des fermes dans
certaines régions de france qui
n'appartiennent plus à des agriculteurs
propre c'est-à-dire en propre donc ou
cdd société d'investissement qui sont
acquis qu'ils achètent
voilà merci beaucoup monsieur desmarest
d'avoir répondu ce matin en direct à nos
questions sur rt france